(siren blaring)
- [Mark] Okay, sorry, what was your name?
- Rosie.
- Mm-hmm.
- [Mark] Rosie, where
are you from originally?
- I'm from La Sierra.
- [Mark] Where is that?
- Somewhere across country.
- [Mark] In the United States?
- No, somewhere in Mexico.
- [Mark] Oh, in Mexico.
- Mm-hmm.
- [Mark] And how long you been in the US?
- Like 42 years old.
- [Mark] You're 42?
- 42.
- [Mark] Tell me about your mom and dad.
- Never seen them.
- [Mark] Oh, you never
saw your mom and dad.
- No.
- [Mark] Who raised you?
- My grandparents.
- [Mark] Your grandparents.
And how was your childhood
with your grandparents?
- Good.
- [Mark] It was fine?
- Mm-hmm.
- [Mark] What got you out
to California, to Skid Row?
- Smoking crack.
- [Mark] How long you been smoking crack?
- 20 years.
- [Mark] 20 years?
And you're working as a
prostitute on the street?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] How much money
do you make in a day?
- Not much.
I don't work.
- [Mark] Okay, Rosie.
- Yes.
- [Mark] Rosie, welcome back.
- Welcome.
(Mark chuckles)
- [Mark] Rosie, where
are you from originally?
- I'm from Las Vegas.
- [Mark] Las Vegas?
- Mm-hmm.
- [Mark] No, you're from another
country, though, I thought.
- Well, I'm born in another country,
but I was raised in Las Vegas.
- [Mark] Really?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] What country are you from?
- Mexico, Guerrero.
(speaking foreign language)
- [Mark] Tell me about your childhood.
You grew up with both parents, one parent?
- No, I grew up with my grandparents.
- [Mark] Your grandparents.
- They were pretty old.
And they didn't know how to do anything,
work and work and work.
- [Mark] Oh, really.
Where were your parents?
- One of them came to the United States.
The other one, I don't know,
he was always here.
- [Mark] And so, you grew
up with your grandparents.
- Yes, I did.
- [Mark] How was that?
That was generally okay, or?
- No, it was bad because
there was never money.
There was nothing to do.
Some things we would need,
some things we would want.
It was all about money.
People always left my life, you know?
No one ever stayed in my
life, it was too calm.
- [Mark] You left home at what age?
- [Rosie] I left home at
the age of 10 years old.
- 10?
- Mm-hmm.
- [Mark] 10 years old, you left home.
Where'd you go?
- [Rosie] Foster care.
- [Mark] So you stayed in
foster care for how long?
- [Rosie] Roster home until I was 18.
- [Mark] Till you were 18.
And how old are you now?
- [Rosie] 28.
- [Mark] 28, so, from foster home at 18,
you left and went where?
- [Rosie] Well, I think I'm 30.
(Mark chuckles)
Yeah, I'm pretty old.
'Cause you know where
you're in the streets,
you don't see that.
- [Mark] Yeah, you lose track.
- [Rosie] You lose track of everything.
- [Mark] You don't know what
week is it right now, do you?
- [Rosie] No, I miss my home.
I miss that star in my
eyes telling me every day
how's your life today.
How are you?
- [Mark] Nobody's asking
you any of that stuff here?
- [Rosie] No.
- [Mark] They just wanna
take advantage of you.
- [Rosie] They always take my money.
You know, the $20 you gave me?
- [Mark] So I gave you $20
last time and what happened?
- I gave him $10 and he say I took off
without giving him anything.
So they always fuck my money.
It's like the street's the devil.
It has money, it's always devil work.
The fucking devil.
It's like he owns the money.
He owns the street.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Like my friend on the corner,
he always fucks me with
dimes, 20s, or crystal.
But he only does like when he first starts
getting into shit.
You know what mean,
when you first get the cut
and you tell him how much is for him
and what he gotta sell?
Yeah, he's helps me out.
You know when you have a home,
it's a give you're given
to know and have the knowledge
of knowing there are things like
how's your star today, you know?
How are you?
But the streets also could
give me something, too.
The knowledge of knowing how it was
and say where do I want to go from there.
So, pretty much I like it so far.
I like what I'm doing with my life.
- [Mark] You like it here?
- Yeah, like helping people.
I love people.
I say I couldn't live without them.
- [Mark] So you help them by,
so men are picking you up.
I guess my question is
do you have sex with men?
- Yes, I do.
- [Mark] For money.
- Yes, I have to.
- [Mark] Yes, just to,
for a girl like you that's-
- A girl like me who grew up with nothing
got nothing to lose and
got nothing to gain.
- [Mark] It's an easy, quick
way to make money, right?
- Yes.
It's an easy way.
But you know what, it's
not always like that.
People don't always think like that.
- [Mark] Sometimes it's dangerous, huh?
- Oh, very.
- [Mark] What kind of
crazy things have you seen?
- [Rosie] People choke me, kick.
I seen this girl got beat
the fuck down the other day.
- [Mark] All right,
Rosie, thank you so much
for talking to me.
- [Rosie] Okay, now I can I get paid?
- [Mark] Appreciate it, thank you.